so I look up at the stars to guide me
and throw go to Every warning sign I'm
sure there will be challenges that find
me but I can take them on one at a time
well the first time I heard this wish um
it was shortly after I'd been told I got
the job and I was so thrilled and so
excited and grateful and then I heard
the song it was like oh my God so one of
the most beautiful things I'd ever heard
and you know the incredible Julia
Michaels like has outdone herself in my
opinion because this song does feel and
is a new Disney classic but it also has
this beautiful sound of today so I it
just felt like I was like this is moving
us forward it's like Disney can take on
a new sound and feeling
unapologetically and so that's
horrifying when you realize you're the
one charged with executing this well um
but I'm I have a theater background so I
did what I do best which is go through
and focus on the lyric and find the
truth of that so every line is rooted in
something emotional for me um whether it
be one of asha's memories or one of my
own like isn't truth supposed to set you
free that's the question that's what
it's supposed to do then why do I feel
so weighed down by it and I remember it
I mean I've had an experience in the
last two weeks of what that felt like
and I was
like it hurts and yet the only way that
I find my freedom is by speaking my
truth and her truth is you know so I
make this wish to have something more
for us than this that's how I got
through that
[Music]
song
something oh I cried buckets and buckets
and but I also had these moments of like
yeah get him and you know I'm very
reactive audience member but it was kind
of odd cuz I was like is that's my voice
this is very strange but I am rooting
for this girl and these people but I
loved Chris Pine I thought he was so
delicious his King magnifico is sexy am
I allowed to say that I don't know but
it's great character delicious Disney
villain it's
good they were quite a few I mean I wore
out the Beauty and the Beast and the
Aladdin vhs's like wore them out loved
him so much but then I also like Tarzan
was really special to me that was when I
really like was introduced to the sound
of Glen
Close what like break your heart voce so
beautiful um and trash in the camp was
like the the the rhythmic nature of that
and like how Rhythm and can tell a story
and it I don't know I was I felt very
young but it was very profound for me so
those were very important
films all you have to
do is give your wish to
me well my favorite I can't talk
about which isn't helpful like that was
not a helpful thing for me to say um but
I think you know it's probably more
obvious but I if you look at the
animation Style like from the first uh
scene you know for me I'm like H sleepy
beauty it's beautiful that's one of my
favorite films so it's like it we we
start and then it just goes and goes and
goes it's like if you haven't noticed
the like the house and Wonderland
climbing down the rabbit hole yet point
that out cuz it's cute it made my heart
go pitter Pat just
saying at the stars to guide me and
throw gosh into every warning
no which is an odd thing to say I mean I
I know my mother has a video type of me
somewhere when I was probably five or
six singing part of your world because
they re-released uh The Little Mermaid
like they I think they' remastered it
and there was a featurette with like the
music video and you could sing along
with it which I loved um so I did and
she recorded had like a little
microphone and everything but in my
adulthood
no I don't think so I think you know
this wish is is holding that down for me
it is the song of my life that is what
is so crazy it's like if anybody ask me
a question about how I'm feeling about
the world today I'm just like go listen
to this wish and I stand by it sure
there will be challenges that me but I
can take them on one at a
time no you know what's so odd this has
been Mo the most magical and very it was
an odd experience too because I didn't
see uh different you know uh members of
our creative team until different points
so it's like we had made like half the
movie and then I really got to chat with
Jennifer and I was like oh my God girl
you're so amazing and she was like no
you're amazing and we just had an
amazing Fest which was really fun and
and I mean I love her I love her work in
Frozen so smart again like I feel like
anytime you see you know Jennifer Lee's
name or you see a Chris Buck's name or
now fawn's name you know that Disney is
taking something to the next level and
that's exciting and very scary for
someone like me but I'm thrilled to be a
part of
[Music]
it
R you can turn all
toing
no I don't know um maybe it's called I
don't
know I don't know I don't know
Julia you need to help me with these
lyrics I mean honestly it' probably be
called I'm
Alive something in that nature because I
I value life I really do I
value you know making it through some of
the challenges that I faced you know
some of the adversity the criticism the
the the closed doors like living to see
another day to have the opportunity to
be better is such a gift to me so I
would probably something along those
lines
all
city I would
love to find a balance with social media
I think we're living in a time where you
know for very good reason but people are
very reactive and it's very hard to you
know have conducive or productive
convers ation on that platform and it
makes me sad because I do think that it
can be a positive tool for change but
sometimes there's so much misinformation
and I think sometimes people are not
doing the homework or just the work of
finding you know uh reliable sources and
it's very easy to jump on a bandwagon
without doing your research and I refuse
to do that and I have always been
someone that tries
to put you know my best foot forward
with with putting positive energy out
there sharing sound sources um and try
trying to help find Solutions but
sometimes you know sometimes silence is
a good choice so that you can learn so
that you can hear and hold space for
others social media is a very me me
platform and you know what I'm tired of
me I'm interested in other people and
what their lives look like how can I be
of service to them um and I think you
know my wish right now is that we could
all try to listen to each other each
other better I'm so nervous I think I'm
going to explode my best friend the
king's Apprentice my mouth trooping I
feel like it's trooping oh it's such an
honor it's such an honor and I I think
the the best thing that I can hope and
wish for is that I will this this this
space that I have been given the
privilege to occupy it responsibly that
is my goal and and if I do my my job
well you know hopefully people will be
inspired by this character they will be
inspired by this film it will make them
feel good it will fill them with hope
and then we will launch ourselves into a
new chapter on a good note you know I
think God wouldn't that be nice to leave
2023 on a good
note for free and I don't even charge
you rent I clean up all your messes and
I'm always say when you need to I give
and give and give and give you'd think
they'd all be content and all I really
want is just a little respect and this
is the thanks I my favorite part about
being a bad is just it's more fun it's
just simply way way more fun in terms of
putting my own spin on I just did you
know me I didn't really there's no um
extra sauce on it I don't think yes yes
yes yes I'm couldn't be more happy happy
to have at least attempted to to reach
the heights of you know Scar and Jafar
and gastone and the rest of the gang um
I was such an honor to work with Ben and
Julie on music that was so creative and
challenging and
difficult and um again it was just a lot
of fun it was really
challenging
bit if you really needed that i' be the
first one to volunteer Henry if your
home word crumble there's a lot of
nerves all over the process it's just as
long as you get time in the booth you
know it's like you get first couple
takes to burn off the anxiety and you
burn through it you burn through it and
then like five minutes and you're kind
of still remembering some of the anxiety
and then 30 minutes and you're in Flow
State and that's when you're rocking and
rolling in terms of the process I worked
with with with Julie and Ben and her
lyrics are very complicated in terms of
their phrasing or it's very particular
uh which made it difficult and a great
challenge um Ben is such a sweetheart
and so gifted working with you know with
with artists and helping us through uh
challenging parts of the song um I
worked with great uh kind of vocal
Specialists and people helping me with
all of it with warming up and with um
finding those right notes and the right
pictures and whatnot Asha come with me
the wishes of Rosas wow people give
their wishes to me and I grant the
wishes I am sure are good ver rosis it
was great I mean like I'm a I'm a
stickler so there are things where I was
like I don't know why they chose that
take I would have chosen a different one
all of those things that happen every
time you see a film of yours uh but I
was thrilled with it I mean the the you
know this was in cinemascope and 255 the
ratio is huge so it's like a giant film
experience it's uh watercolored so
there's a lot of analog vibe to it so it
feels old but also with this very new
uh CG B so has this textural immersion
it doesn't feel so like clean which I
don't really like of newer stuff has a a
density and it but it feels very present
so that was wild um hearing all the
songs come together was was great um
yeah it was a lot of fun I believe I
have just been threatened who would dare
threaten
you I have no response to that yeah it's
it's a big uh I feel like a big pat on
the back like that's really cool you
asked me to come play on like what is a
big deal for maybe the most important uh
entertainment organization at least for
kids I mean I think
about if you're a kid on planet Earth
you've been touched by something that
Disney has created and the fact that
they have such an imprint on
storytelling is kind of
jaw-dropping um I think about my own
experience and that it's so kind of
ingrained in My DNA that I don't even
think of all of the every single film
that I've seen when I was growing up
animated um so I loved it and getting to
work with Ariana and getting to work
with Vicor Garber and Jennifer and and
and Chris and fun all these people that
have extraordinary experience in this
space was great fun there is a traitor
amongst us find
Asha every it's a dead end with unsanded
mahogany I mean I I like the kind of the
one straight off the bat which is star
uh to wish upon a star beautiful elegant
tie-in there the seven you know dwarf
reference I think is pretty pretty spot
on and pretty
cool I started this I have to finish
it I think seeing Fantasia I think it
was at the Pantages just kind of blew my
mind I felt like it was the first
psychedelic experience I'd ever had yeah
it was so far out yeah last night I made
a wish on a
star uh on the star
answered oh I think you know um the goat
is pretty funny I mean star is so cute
star is the one you want to toy of you
know I'd say star three two one Asha I'm
here I'm here just one second they I
mean the the in the booth all the time
during the recording sessions for for um
the the acting it was Fawn and Chris and
the sound editor um Jennifer and um her
co-screenwriter
um a couple other folks but yeah it was
kind of an and some producers so the
amalgam of that was
getting suggestions pretty much from all
places which I I didn't mind at all um
but most of my kind of like
dramaturgical questions about like a
line or the syntax of something I'd
always just pitch to Jennifer like I
don't really understand what you're
trying to go for why are we talking
about this right now um but I had this
kind of you know
great um Brain Trust there and then in
terms of the singing stuff it was all
Ben and and um and Julia and Ben
particularly when he was handling the
the the engineering oh what are you
doing Valentino don't eat
[Music]
that it didn't work when does the magic
happen
H I'm talking I am talking who knew my
voice would be this low there were so
many magical moments but I will the the
one moment that I think um stands out
because of the the uh incredible
Discovery it was for the film is when we
were talking about star and whether star
should talk and what is star really
can't do the work for you Ash has to do
it herself well star really is all those
things that Disney gives us hope
possibility Wonder joy that doesn't tell
you the answers it's just there for you
when you need it and um one of the story
artists drew a little just ball of light
and said no
voice but they and will smile when you
need them maybe a little magic and that
is when I I in in a funny way with all
the dialogue I'd written for star before
this moment the surrendering of star
doesn't talk and star doesn't have the
answers but is there for hope I knew
exactly what to do with star so that was
the most magical moment for me and there
were and that's a lot because there were
many on the film this is something I
haven't told anyone about um in this
today but star loves yarn and strings
and stuff and it was a little nod to um
the the physicists out there who love
String Theory as a as part of the
universe and that's not what string
theory is because no one knows
understands it I certainly don't but
that little obsession with yarn was such
a fun
character trait for me and really
grounded to bring Stars ideas forward
without talking as well and I think that
was one of the fun really fun things
that I love to play with and then
through all the things Star would create
um that was a fun but a very specific
thing to star that that we discovered
that isn't like you know um I don't know
it's it's it's a it felt like not every
Star will do that but star this star
would do that so I make this
[Applause]
something more for us this it was a very
unique process because I hadn't written
the script yet I don't even know if I
was maybe I was planning to write it but
I was just we were in this role we were
talking about Asha and knowing we wanted
that moment as a teenager where you you
living your life everything's fine and
then all of a sudden you're like hey
that's not right and you and I always
say it's a very generous time teenagers
are the ones who want to make the world
better for others we give them a bad rep
sometimes that they're selfish and I'm
like they're the ones who can see a
better world and that's woman who
doesn't know she can have the courage to
do it and it's but her want is more for
for those it's around her so it's not I
want love it's I want more for them and
that generous the generosity of that is
where the star was like well then I'm
going to come help you as opposed to
just thanks for the wish you know and it
was just such a fun idea and we
described that to Julia we didn't hadn't
written the scripts we described this
young woman at that moment moment we
described the feeling and she came back
with this wish and when I heard the line
you know I've mentioned it before I'm
I'm young but I'm not wrong I was like
oh gosh I it just that's the feeling
when you're that age and you go through
it and I and that whole song was there
for me when I wrote the script so it's
it was there's often the chicken and egg
in this case that was definitely first
so I guess it's the egg that was the egg
I was the chicken you don't have to look
too hard it's all around not to far try
to figure out just who you are you're a
star I think what's interesting about
Anna and Elsa is like Anna is there's a
traditional sense of Anna she wants love
obviously her journey that we get to
flip tropes and really look at what does
it really mean and what is love and and
Elsa is very magical but she is she is
really crippled by fear and that having
Anna help they help each other um is
really what makes them that very
specific but Asha wants as we said she
she's got a fighting spirit in her but
she wants more for her world and so but
she but she's still I think there's
always an a an optimism and naive when
we begin a journey in some form so
that's where they connect but what I
love about Asha is in that Declaration
of I wish she's forced to face careful
what you wish for now you've now it's on
you to make it come true and you see her
fight every step of the way and
hopefully say to people
you know it is hard the journey is hard
when it's a true wish like that but it's
worth it and she Rises to be a very
different kind of leader and what I love
most is while Anna figures out love you
know she becomes one of the great
helpers of the world and that is a is
wholly her own and and I do think that
beautiful benevolence of her that she is
she's completely a typical teenager
she's of spirit she even made like maybe
I'll get this job and yeah maybe things
will come out of it she's so but as
challenged and I think when you're
challenged your true nature comes she
Rises to recognize that that's her
greatest gift is her her compassion for
others
work
theep want to know you are I'm a star
we're here it it it feels I like we're I
think we talk about as a team we process
and as a studio we're kind of processing
the excitement of that and the the there
there's a sense of privilege that we get
to be a part of it and that we got to
create something for it but what's been
most beautiful is never have I fully
understood the power of all of our
individual connections to that Legacy
and there are Folks at the studio you
know we we got you know Bernie matens
said had been here 70 years and he was
working with the youngest story artist
just up until right before a week before
he passed away and um and I'm I'm
getting to work very closely with Eric
Goldberg who you know Mastermind hand um
handron animator of the genie and and
Chris Buck had worked with the original
9 men and their stories they this brings
them to tell all the stories because
they they're nostalgically thinking
about those hundred years and then each
of us talking about our first film and
our in every moment that Disney was
there as a light for us um we're all
sharing not just in this film but we're
sharing in the entire Disney every you
know for most of us it's one of our
earli memory so whether you're 34 or 52
um we're sharing those and so it's
really bringing us together in this way
that I always say wow it really shows us
how much more we're connected than we
often
[Music]
realize yeah my very first was Bambi um
which was quite powerful uh I was only
five but I think the one though that was
with me
from I didn't get to see it till I was a
little older but I had the book book
when I was I mean my sister said I was
two probably when I was going on on with
Cinderella and then she I she got me
through Middle School when I was bullied
a lot and uh she was there every
afternoon and she persevered through
some bullying so um I know every frame
of that movie I know every object I know
every line like it's just it's it's
there and it's it's I even have in my
office um they brought um prints from
the ARL of the her D in in 12 drawings
of her dress transformation for
me I
wish who whoa what was that well I'm
very I I I don't know I'm very close to
this film right now and I'm very close
to Asha and I think as we navigate an
Ever more complex world that seems to be
finding ways to divide us more and more
I think like Asha is just hoping we find
these ways to just see how much more
we're actually connected Ed and let the
power of that help us through
it I only can say that I'm I I wasn't in
the animation room most of the time in
this film because I'm that not being a
director on the film but I'd heard about
that one of the things we did um at d23
when we first announced the film is we
invited folks there was a wall with the
word wish on it and we invited folks to
put their own wish on a little sticky
that of stars and put them on the wall
and they actually every we've been doing
this for about a year now every day here
we have a wall and we we kept all those
wishes and we add another one so the
wall it's up it's upstairs the wall has
started with one and now the whole wall
is full as we approach the the film
coming out and that starting the trigger
of everyone connecting with their wish
and then that celebration of bringing
those forward were all just little in a
nursery from supernovas now we've grown
into our history
I'm going to
exclude the parts the films I've got to
work on because I think the relationship
with that is just so much more intense
than anything that I Nothing Compares
but I think um Cinderella So This is
Love I love that song and that when his
voice cuts through all love um I love
that and I over and over again I have
listened to that and watched it um and I
think think actually Part of Your World
I was about 17 or 18 when Little Mermaid
came out and I was just about to go to
college and I think that that um idea of
going out into the world was there and I
horribly sang that over and over again
so in you know in my little Chevy chevet
that no one could hear me and
so
hang mushrooms you so your dust is my
dust I will say cuz it cuz I had never
seen seen Cinderella that's what's weird
is I'm old enough that they didn't they
would re-release them in theaters and
that was before VHS which came out when
I was about 12 or 13 is when Cinderella
came out on VHS so I think I was eight
or nine when it came out in the theater
and I'd had the books ID had the ID had
the record that played the voices but it
was the first time I'd ever seen it and
I I I remember just the minute we I'm
like can we go right back in again and
at the time we're like no that's it's
expensive but I was like oh so that one
for me because it was one that I had
been dreaming about or thinking about
and had never just to now we have the
availability to see them all all the
time uh I don't I didn't have that so it
really made it truly special some of
these will never be granted not some
most they deserve more than I decide
what everyone deserves oh yeah I mean I
think Ariana it was she was so
inspirational to you know just like all
of the actors are and like Anna um is
very inspired by Kristen Bell and her
personality is with with um Ariana she
is such a generous warm soul and she's
very giving and she cares very deeply
about other people and how they feel and
that came through with Asha when Asha
has a hard time telling her grandfather
the news but has to that was a hard
scene for Ariana and it helped me to
understand how seriously Asha takes the
pain that could be caused by any of her
choices really drove me and then of
course I mean she can s anything and
she's so physical when she communicates
and because she's a dancer so that
inspired I know the animators with Asha
Chris Pine is someone who I just think
he's he's brilliant he has incredible
charm so magnifico as much as he could
be charming and he could be a villain he
had to be brilliant and he and Chris
really is someone who loves to
understand all the motivations of the
characters and so understanding every
moment of magnifico's life was important
so we would work on that hard and then a
lot of that ended up in the
movie